people would come up with me and they'd  say sir  my campaign  sir do you ever hear anything about  russia  i said no not really i mean russia is  russia right  they're ripping us off just like every  other country in the world now by the  way they're really ripping us because of  what they've done with energy they're  making a fortune because of it  i ended the pipeline and he approved it  but he knocked out the keystone didn't  he huh  but they say sir an innocent young great  people they love our country sir  another one coming up a couple of months  later sir did you ever hear anything do  anything about russia  no  then the third one comes up a month left  sir  do you have anything to do with russia  this is too much no  after about four or five times you know  the way it is i said  what the hell is going on with russia  and that's what's going on with russia  they made up a hoax and we had to live  with it for three years what kind of a  sick perverted mind does that